[Music]
a million people displaced hospitals
bombed children forced to flee for their
lives and a world apparently indifferent
to their plight that's the reality of
life inside Syria's last rebel
stronghold this week Sky News spent 48
hours there and found a city under siege
with evidence of war crimes and an
unfolding humanitarian disaster in this
special program we'll hear from the
children the mothers the doctors the
fighters and the victims and we'll hear
the growing calls for international
action to save the lives of those caught
up in the horror inside evening
[Music]
at just 20 days old testings already
endured unbearable hardship she's
desperately hungry but a tiny stomach so
small she can barely ingest anything she
was born to a mother on the run and has
spent her entire short life in a tent so
bitterly cold her heart all but stopped
and there are so many more like Tesla
who are suffering the doctors say about
half a dozen babies come in every day
desperately undernourished or born
prematurely to traumatize mothers more
than 70 hospitals have already been put
out of action this is one of the few
left operating inside Edelen dr. Ikram
is overwhelmed with young patients she's
a mother of two pregnant again and
clearly angry in her office she breaks
down furious at the inaction by the
world's leaders but the bombing isn't
stopping listen to that breathing
there's real terror about another attack
on the same place it's a common tactic
somehow the elderly owner walks out
alive it's serious most vulnerable who
are most affected and those first on the
scene worry every time about seeing the
dead uninjured
I think in many many times
[Music]
the aircraft is gone now you can see
this the sense of trepidation whenever a
drone comes up then an aircraft comes a
jet comes and they think right we're
gonna be next
it's terrorizing close by a hospitals
hit a short time later spotters have
seen the aircraft and the patients have
been shifted all the parties in this
conflict are given GPS locations for the
medical facilities here attacking
hospitals is an international war crime
they want us to be killed they don't
want to hear us they do they want us to
be killed in science the fighting and
war crimes on both sides have prompted
mass movement of families trying to get
out of the battlefield and they're still
moving the bulk of them women and
children and as the regime troops close
in they're running out of places to run
to hamaji making any man
and in revenue yeah scary a man even
Turkish troops are in Eid Lib
threatening to take on the regime whilst
politicians scramble to stop all-out war
for the civilians Wars already here and
from the very old to the very young here
at least they fear of Bashar al-assad
[Music]
children far too knowledgeable about war
whilst idli burns with no end in sight
our hospital received an enormous number
of patient who has been recently
displaced so we work around the clock to
accommodate all patients who visit our
facility and so as you know that
Northwest two-year represents now one of
the world's most humanitarian crises and
in the middle aspects the situation is
disasters as the the sea Luigi regime
attack hospital deliver deliberately the
situation is too difficult for us we are
unable to meet the needs for our
patients as the lack of fund and the
lack of equipments we received from the
international community
we expect the famine and communicable
diseases and unfortunately babies dying
from the weather from sub-zero
temperature we are preparing ourself for
all the scenarios in the future and to
even to evacuate our hospital and to
relocate to other part but we will tell
here in Italy with our people with the
civilians to save life as possible as we
can we know we risk our our life to help
the civilians the injured people and we
go to our work knowing that we may not
return our home simply that's our duty
the majority of injuries and our
casualties that were civilian and the
vast majority of them were wave
war-related injuries however as our
hospital have to cover now 1 million
displaced people near the borders we
have to cover all other diseases such as
chronic disease but the majority is
war-related injuries
I work with dr. Omar several for several
years now
mm 12 13 14 16 and I was with him in
July last year training him with the
other doctors as well they've always had
a problem with shortage of materials and
lots of problems of getting blood and
helping patients and so and so forth and
it's always been a huge problem for them
and it's okay to give them all the
advice you could possibly give them to
dealing with fragmentation wounds and
gunshot wounds and so on but if you
haven't got the equipment as well to
deal with it then it's a big problem and
of course what they've got now is
thousands upon thousands of injured
people who they're trying to deal with
with with hardly any equipment I'm
really astounded that it's just got as
bad as it has I mean the Syrian
government and the Sira the Russian
regime and the Iranians are totally out
of control
and there are being allowed to almost
exterminate countless hundreds and
thousands of Syrian civilians and of
course when you think about it 70% of
all the people the civilians are women
and children
nevermind the problem that women have
that they're probably pregnant they've
got no hospitals to go to 18 of the
hospitals they had several weeks ago
have now been destroyed there's only
three left and certainly babble Hauer
where I was when the people came up from
Aleppo and they were in a dreadful state
in 2016 I operated on many of those with
dr. Omar when they when they all came up
and then there only people you ever see
are in fact civilians you don't see any
of the so-called jihadis and you're only
operating on children and women and old
people and that's what the problem is
and it's a real real ordeal for
everybody and I have a suspicion that if
we don't do anything about it in the
next few weeks then there could be close
to a million people losing their lives
it's as bad as that we need to cut
across the lines because if nobody else
is doing anything we just can't sit back
and watch the catastrophe that's
unfolding in front of us and listen to
dr. Omar who calls me
every day to say that situations getting
worse and worse and worse than they've
run out of money they've run out of
equipment they've run out of everything
and we I've personally can't feel that I
can sit here and listen to him crying to
me every day and we've got to do
something in the West really now need to
do something and I think the West are
sitting back and they're running away
and I wish they would
[Music]
view from Turkey the war in Syria is
threatening to burst its banks in these
camps a hundreds of thousands of Syrians
who know the Assad regime is closing in
and they're cornered pressed up against
Turkey's border the UN says they're now
being bombed and shelled in the camps
prompting the starkest of warnings
there are about a million displaced
people living in camps and makeshift
shelters in that area and you know if
the shelling and airstrikes move any
further into that area we're gonna see a
bloodbath we're gonna see a massacre on
a scale that has never been seen and
during this entire war a complete
humanitarian collapse in aid Lib could
force hundreds of thousands of Syrians
across this border and threaten a repeat
of Europe's migrant crisis the other
looming danger an escalating conflict
between Turkey and Syria and Russia
could do the same and that is looking
increasingly likely
column after column of Turkish heavy
armor is being sent to the border and
offensive his imminent says Turkey after
talks with Russia broke down threatening
a whole new chapter in this devastating
conflict in an orphanage we were shown
how Syrian children are told to draw
what they wish for was therapy for the
trauma of losing their homes and parents
wish to go to paradise to see his
fathers and mothers because the mark the
father and the mother they're in
paradise therapist by on is from it'd
Lib and deeply worried about those she
left behind the people were where they
go the Turkish or turkey here they
didn't open the door
person people it's no things and what's
it it's me it's me that I said we kill
Oh life people's now there is no place
get really is no place to go there's no
place left he fought against thigh
we met Syrian rebel commander Ahmed
berry who fought Islamic state after
defecting from the Assad regime he
expected the world to intervene years
ago he said and stop Assad and it's now
almost given up hope and Mantha who Omar
Marshall when monster of Shavuot Surya
sham.murphy successfully obtained Mian
Abdullah 1713 America Oh Britannia
Oh France ow almani a dual Ozma nano le
sorry Surya masala Erica
the world has wrung its hands apparently
impotent to stop serious carnage for
almost a decade but over this border is
a killing zone where millions are now
trapped at this 11th hour will it now
act
I think the important thing to remember
is that the UN wants to act and 13
members of the Security Council want to
act but were stopped from acting because
of Russia supported by China that's
that's the main thing to get the
Russians to restrain the Syrians and to
stop aiding them in the bombings that
they're doing including bombings of
hospitals which is against the Geneva
Convention we've had the
secretary-general we've had the High
Commissioner for Human Rights pleading
for this to stop and for there to be a
ceasefire that's a call that we back
we're very ready to do what we can to
support a un-led ceasefire but Russia
would need to agree and that's the bit
that's missing I think it's important to
remember that the Turks of lost soldiers
because of a Syrian offensive and also
that the Turks have been trying to get a
ceasefire or at least a cessation of
hostilities in place
I think the veto does work in certain
circumstances the real problem is that
the Russians abuse it to protect someone
like Assad who is attacking his own
people
[Music]
Italy was the last bastion of rebel
fighters many of whom allied to al-qaeda
but it's also become a haven for people
fleeing the fighting in other parts of
Syria who have seen the destruction the
regime has inflicted in April Syria's
President Bashar al-assad amplified his
attacks on those rebels who had escaped
to it'd Lib by November although a
significant swathe of territory was
recaptured the conflict ramped up even
further and the violence intensified in
the subsequent months pro-assad forces
have captured dozens more villages
pushing the rebels back into a smaller
and smaller area as the front line has
moved the internally displaced people
have had an increasingly limited space
to seek sanctuary as the pro assad
forces pushed into it Lib those
displaced populations were caught in the
crossfire in the early phase in May 18
hospitals in the Northwest were hit
within the space of two weeks the
Rattler hospital was struck four times
by warplanes allied to the Syrian
government Russian planes are operating
in Syria but Russia denies any attacks
on civilians as the front line has moved
refugees have an increasingly limited
space to seek sanctuary in the last few
months according to the United Nations
some 800,000 people who have been forced
to leave their homes there are now
thousands of people streaming across
northwestern Syria desperate to find
somewhere they can shelter
[Music]
in the desperation and deprivation of
war it is possible to find joy in the
smallest things for ten-year-old Abdul
Rahman and his 12 year old sister regard
that joy is the bicycle they share
for months now there's has been a life
on the move
alive fleeing bombing and death a life
with an eye always on the skies looking
and listening for what is coming next
they and thereby somehow so far
survival lalala heck of a move a diner
move addictive a - wailing Allah
that's Mahad Brickner commands are
available based originally on a little
bit more dynamic way sorry I'm Annie
Annie so bacteria and I magnify
technical sabudana Magnusson effect
Amontillado saboteur Thibodeau hockey my
Vicente in Casa firma firma pega so
freaky sub to Hecky FEMA gives ability
[ __ ] a half of the arable looked in
the digital age a refugee camp we have
to tear over number over narrow honor
after another over the rebuttal
Allah
they are the waves of the innocent the
unknowing for the truth is they have a
long and dangerous road in front of them
often it is best to travel by night out
of sight of those who would do them harm
and every stop even in the darkness has
its poor mercy after several hours they
arrive at the camp where their cousins
have already taken refuge regard and
Abdulrahman have made this journey with
their uncle their mother and father have
stayed behind in the last place they
called home they pray they will come in
the next few days in the tent they play
a game to take their minds off wall
who knows where these young feet will
have to carry them next cost in Sky News
on the syria-turkey border
[Music]
we've lost about seven children frozen
to death according to the United Nations
and absolutely biblical exodus of people
from their homes 130,000 in the space of
three or four days 900,000 over the
space of three months and I think
frankly the pictures that you are
showing the stories that you're telling
should really shame the countries that
are both perpetrating the crimes that
we're seeing the bombing of hospitals
and health centers the bombing of
civilians fleeing but also those
countries who are turning away and
saying that there's nothing that they
can do this now is a threat not just to
the civilians on the ground but to the
peace and security of the whole region
nevermind to Europe because of course if
there is to be a further exodus across
the border into Turkey that will rebound
into Europe and that's why it demands
the highest level of attention it's a
complicated situation there are a
terrorist forces they work they used to
be called jabhat al-nusra and now it's
hariette Torreya al sham it's a branch
of al Qaeda we we're told there are 10
to 15,000 of those buried amongst the
civilians but then you have a range of
other groups non-state actors some of
which are linked to Turkey some of which
have been moved from other parts of
Syria because remember the three million
people in Italy province at the moment
constitute one and a half million people
from Italy and then one and a half
million people from elsewhere in the
country so it's a highly complicated
situation but that just raises the point
that simply bombing from the air missile
strikes on hospitals and civilians
that's not going to undermine the
terrorists position and so I think
anyone who cares about the longer term
stability never mind the short term
humanitarian need has got to recognize
that this bombing and missile campaign
is a complete dead end
the world is failing not just washing
its hands the world is not working
effectively diplomatically but nor is
the humanitarian work going on in the
right kind of way there aren't enough
trucks going over there aren't enough
medical supplies for goodness sake
you've got 50,000 people literally
living under trees in circumstances
where it's minus seven to minus 11
degrees centigrade if that isn't a
shame and a disgrace in the 21st century
I don't know what is
[Music]
so it really doesn't bear thinking about
what it must be like for hundreds of
thousands of people stuck between the
fighting and this border that remains
resolutely closed it may be the final
onslaught but it is by no means the end
of the misery
you